schotte zwei fragen einig kommen wir mal
zu was anderes wenn alle punkt
machtwechsel ist bombe gewonnen
ein feature mit kool savas und video
zusammen
die zweite wäre was hast du gegen elke
132 erstmal danke dass du das album
supported das freut mich wenns dir
gefällt zu deiner ersten frage song und
video mit kool savas und savas sind auf
dem weg dahin gerade freunde zu werden
ich mag ihn sehr wir sind im kontakt
miteinander und wir gucken was die
zukunft bringt wir werden auf jeden fall
eine ehre schöne grüße an der stelle und
savas und zu deiner frage zu haftbefehl
was sollte sagen um gottes willen nicht
in jedem seinen erfolg ich bin kein
missgünstiger menschen missgünstige
menschen erreichen selber nichts im
leben wie gesagt warum ich gedacht habe
und auf diesen 100 bars diese zeiten
gelebt habe habe ich mittlerweile in
vielen interviews erklärt habe es auch
gerade noch mal hier angesprochen und
ich denke damit habe ich oft genug was
zu diesem thema gesagt ich wünsche dir
alles gute
keule 790 fragt warum machst du so eine
pussy rap und kein gangster rap pack
heute 790 ich hatte es auch schon auf
meiner seite geschrieben ich mach ich
denke dass du sagst dass du fragt warum
ich pussycat mache kommt dadurch dass
ich halt einige liebeslieder meiner
karriere ausgekoppelt hat das sind
lieder für frauen demnächst mache ich
lieber für männer und vielleicht sind
die dann weniger positiv sieht chip rap
hat folgende frage was ist für dich eine
[ __ ] eine [ __ ] ist in meinen
augen eine
frau die nicht steht nicht zu dem steht
was sie tut
für mich muss eine frau die offen mit
ihrer sexualität umgeht nicht direkt
zwingt eine [ __ ] sein aber wenn eine
frau irgendwie vorgibt die heilige
jungfrau darstellen zu wollen aber schon
mit hin zum kunst war dann ist das eine
lampe für mich von christoph p ich hab
ein paar fragen an ich erstmal was
hältst du von kollegah und hast du dich
bei der annahme von ea sports
inspirieren lassen oder wie es der
zustande gekommen und was hältst du von
dem erfolg von jung brutal gutaussehend
2 alles klar das war schon meine fragen
geiles album und ciao
hallo kollegah ist ein technisch sehr
krasser rapper ich kenne ihn persönlich
nicht ich hab ich einmal kennengelernt
das aber schon einige jahre her ist ein
krasser rapper erbringt manchmal setzen
da brauche ich immer zehn sekunden und
wenn ich sie verstanden habe bin ich
erst mal ein bisschen baff auf jeden
fall mutter wepper erfolg von jpg 2 ist
killer die beiden sind auf die einzige
karte sind jetzt glaube ich immer noch
an der top ten sind gold gegangen
und das ist was sehr gutes für hip
hopper sehr gutes für etwas ein
independent- act es schaffen kann so
weit nach oben zu kommen bedeutet auch
für uns dass es mittlerweile wieder
jeder schaffen kann wer richtig gas gibt
und wer richtig arbeitet die jungs haben
richtig gearbeitet und deswegen steht
ihnen auch dieser erfolg zu eine letzte
frage war ja bei meinem namen ps ports
habe ich mich wirklich von ea sports
inspirieren lassen da war ich aber noch
sehr jungen aber so hat sich halt auch
der bekanntheitsgrad nach außen
entwickelt und das ist bis heute so
geblieben und ich bin mein name einfach
geil
januar 24 möchte wissen wie ist dein
verhältnis zur sido beziehungsweise wie
stehst du zu ihm und was hältst du von
ihm
sido hat ein klassik album meinen augen
sein zweites album ich fand ich richtig
krass ich finde seine musik war seit dem
schrott ich habe ihn einmal kennen
gelernt und kann auch nicht wirklich was
mit seiner persönlichkeit anfangen bis
hierher und trotzdem wünsche ich ihm
alles gute ich habe gehört er wird jetzt
ein zweites mal vor
gesundheit und ein schönes leben noch
carlos famose was tor von julien spock
ich fand ihn zu gegebenen zeiten witzig
aber jetzt mittlerweile habe ich gewisse
dinge gesehen ja da macht die für mich
einfach ich weiß nicht ich finde einfach
der junge hat keine erziehung genossen
ist respektlos und total verbittert und
keine ahnung vielleicht stirbt er in
hoffentlich servus pay also ich habe
dein album gekauft unterstützen und zwar
beide da springt der fehlt mir noch
auf jeden fall meine frage ja nicht wäre
wann wir die kirmes wieder rauskommen
danke dass du bei der alben gekauft hast
sehr kinder von st das erste album das
debütalbum ist doch leider im handel
nicht mehr erhältlich bereits
ausverkauft ist und auch nicht mehr
nachproduziert wurde aber dazu habe ich
auch bald eine überraschung für meine
fans
hierdurch wird sehr bald aus dem
gefängnis kommen er ist jetzt bald am
ende seiner haftstrafe und sobald er da
ist während wir durch drehen zusammen
ohne matt muss fragt was hältst du von
farid bang
er beleidigte in seinen texten mütter
und alles was sagst du dazu von farid
bang warum so direkt dieser mittel keine
ahnung dass er mit er beleidigt ist
seine entscheidung verriet anderson
punch ein rapper das ist ein ding das
ding für das er sich entschieden hat
macht er sehr gut und ich wünsche dir
viel erfolg
er hat ja auch erfolg und das spricht
fühlen